Đi ràng tháng ligên, khi cầu đồng ý các.
Saum thấy chia sê đau đó,
bên trong có hay phía đến tỏi nên dùng tu phương viết.
Cái chuyện sè đi vào nập.
Thông loại lai vào sè nhạm hay phía đến tỏi.
Trình gọng nân, hay mi chính tuổi,
hay tại cư quan điều tra khi bị công quan lâm đồng mất tậm răm,
để điều tra hình vì chộp cắp tại sản.
Theo điều tra, phụ việc sây ra dạng sáng 2,5 táng tấm nằm,
sau khi lấy được tại sản trong cô tốt đậu bên đường,
nâng dời khỏi hiện trường.
Đến sáng cùng ngày,
khi măng hành điện thoại đi bán,
ngân biệt công quan phát hiện vắt sử.
Theo công quan, đây là lần thứ tu,
ngân thực hiện hành vi trộp cắp.
Người này từng được biết đến với biệt sáng xíu trộm,
liên quan nhiều vụ cải cơ ổ tô đột nhập cơ quan nhắn nước,
và trường học nó là.
Nó là là, chúng cắp tên là nơi sấu,
chúng ta mẹ mát, sau khi tổ vê, sau mọi người,
đại tiếp tục,
chúng ta sẽ xảy ra đi bát.
Bởi ông có ra là,
mở ra tổ sơ mẹ về ra là.
Mò mẹ, nhận là,
mẹ mẹ mẹ có chỉ ngã của giấu,
mẹ sơ.
Mẹ mẹ mẹ sẽ một trở lắm họ nữa,
chúng ta cũng không là nó chú kìa mở cho anh như mây giờ,
thì không có nó cho anh là gì lặng này.
Mẹ mẹ cũng cũng tưởng tiền,
cũng tư sai cái nhớm.